así juramento Joe biden como el
presidente número 46 de Estados Unidos
con fuertes medidas de seguridad tras la
toma del Capitolio unos días antes en su
primer día una premisa revertir las
políticas más dañinas de la era Trump
vamos a combatir el cambio climático de
una forma que nunca antes hicimos
también vamos a reconstruir nuestra
economía esta serían las claves de su
primer año vacunación masiva contra el
covid-19 vuelta a los acuerdos
climáticos de París y un proyecto de
inversión Estatal para relanzar la
economía a largo plazo una economía
marcada en estos dos años por la alta
inflación que apenas ahora comienza a
descender por contra vaiden no hizo
realidad sus promesas de revertir las
peores políticas migratorias de Trump
sigue en pie el título 42 que se cobija
en la emergencia sanitaria por la
pandemia para expulsar rápidamente a
migrantes indocumentados en su segundo
año de mandato firmó una orden ejecutiva
para intentar proteger el acceso al
aborto luego que la corte anular al
histórico fallo Rover sus wait que
amparaba la interrupción del embarazo
no podemos permitir a una Corte Suprema
fuera de control que trabaje con los
elementos más extremistas del partido
republicano esto no detuvo una ola de
prohibiciones en los Estados
republicanos en el terreno político
consiguió sorpresivamente minimizar la
victoria republicana en las elecciones
de medio término los demócratas
perdieron la cámara de representantes
pero mantuvieron el senado los
republicanos digamos desplegarán todo su
artillería pero también hay que ver que
el presidente tiene a los demócratas de
su lado en el senado y que también tiene
el derecho del del veto biden ha
impulsado el gasto millonario en ayuda
militar a Ucrania que ha fortalecido su
liderazgo internacional pero entra en su
tercer año de mandato lidiando con la
polémica por los papeles clasificados
encontrados en su residencia sobre los
que avisaron sus propios abogados un
caso por el que los republicanos abrirán
comités de investigación en la cámara de
representantes
encontramos que un puñado de documentos
estaban archivados en el lugar
equivocado inmediatamente los entregamos
al departamento de Justicia para que se
resuelva rápidamente
el mandatario ya anunció su intención de
optar a la reelección en 2024 la
pregunta es si a su avanzada edad
aguantará una nueva carrera presidencial